hello everyone and welcome back to the
capablanca saga we are back at the 1911
tournament of San Sebastian where
Capablanca faces none other than Carl
schlechte Austrian chess master who only
a year before this tournament in San
Sebastiano challenged Emanuele asked her
for the title and he was this close to
winning the match we already mentioned
that first four games ended in a draw
then select a one a game against
Emanuele ask her then for more games
ended in a draw and then slice two just
needed to draw a game and he would be
world champion but he started an attack
against Lasker in the final game then he
blundered which resulted in a drawn
position and then he blundered again and
basically lost the title
some historians suggested that perhaps
she later needed a two-point margin to
actually became become world champion
but there were never any evidence to
these rumors so it's I mean Capablanca
also mentioned that in his magazine that
he was a editor-in-chief and he said
that maybe maybe coach Lester just
didn't want to win the World Chess
Championship title over a fluke as
Alaska blundered in Game five well
either way it's a shame because this
gentleman called so if that could have
been a world chess champion after a
manual a skirt now but that you know
that will be reserved for someone else
and it was also known to be a great
gentleman he's much older than
capablanca here much more experienced
here a couple Blanca is 22 years old
cross where it is I believe 37 and yeah
he was a really huge gentleman if you
were late for your game and your the
time on your clock ran out he would then
fix the time on his clock so he would
have the exact same time as you even
though you're the one that was a late
for the game and also if you said that
you were ill you weren't feeling all
that great he would offer you like a
like a mercy draw not not a lot of
people would do this so maybe maybe he
just saw I don't think anyone ever came
up with this theory but maybe he just
saw that he could become world champion
he could be
her and then he just you know when went
in for a suicide game and let let Alaska
have his title but who knows and also
here is a pretty weird image we already
saw one image of all the participants or
well not all but maybe all of the 1911
tournament of San Sebastiano
here is a an image from the newspapers
there you can see it but although it
names all the players there you can see
in the upper row you have burned Marazzi
learn heart Vidmar and Denise's missus
did not participate in this 1911
tournament of San Sebastiano but even
though it says missus here then sitting
in the bottom row from the left you have
Marshall Bernstein Doris Rubenstein
y'know filmin kappa blanka in the middle
everyone can see him nimzowitsch Dyckman
and tarish so there is no curse letter
in this drawing that was in the
newspapers but missus is there and he
was not playing in this tournament so
that's a bit weird I don't know what
happened there maybe maybe Electra would
just wasn't there when they were doing
drawing or I don't know maybe someone
just thought that Mises was in the
tournament instead of character but you
know it's almost more than it's more
than hundred years ago so it's hard to
hard to say what happens but if anyone
can shed some light to this mystery you
know feel free to do so we would all be
very honored to increase our knowledge
but getting back to the game kappa
blanka has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 we have D five bucks left nice
to have three nights we have six and now
III Bishop to a5 the Col system and now
we have c4 kappa blanka makes room for
his queen to come to b3 as this was his
favorite idea when the bishop was a
light the lights were Bishop was
developed very early so he could develop
the Queen while pressuring the b7 pawn
we have c6 Queen to b3 now with more
pressure to the d5 pawn but also the b7
pawn is under attack and quinta c7 if in
modern times most likely Queen to b6
will be played here rather than Queen to
c7
you'll see why later but I also thought
of a crazy idea I thought what if this
was actually used once to draw the game
like though it's a queen d1 Queen goes
back Queen B 3 Queen goes back and I
checked the database no one ever did
this which I'm very glad I mean it would
be a crime against chess if this
happened but okay Queen B 3 Queen c7 and
now Knight to c3 capablanca keeps on
developing pressures the d5 pawn e6
adding more protection to the pawn and
now Bishop the d2 Knight bd7 slider
keeps developing we have rope to c1 and
now you can continue developing because
there's the threat of winning the pawn
for example in Bishop e7 now you can see
that the rook and Queen are occupying
the same file simply pawn captures pawn
captures Knight captures captures and
queen can capture the Queen and c7 is
undefended here you capture and you lose
the Queen a while grab the pawn and
we'll enjoy a much better position so
after rook c1 Queen back to b6 now here
black has to waste a move for this Queen
c7 to Queen b6 maneuver and you can see
that it would be much better if the
Queen came to b6 instead of c7
altogether now which is why today Queen
b6 is to move that displayed a bar okay
there should be two we have H 6 and now
castles and Bishop to e7 and here kappa
blanka decides the trade of Queens we
have Queen captures pawn captures and
now a3 the knight can now move the
pollinate who is no longer a target and
black has to be better here as black has
the semi open a file for his rook but on
the other hand his pawn structure is
somewhat messed up but it's messed up
towards the center so black has to be
better here we have castles and now rook
F 2 D 1 cup of 1 coverings are not a
rook into the game we have rook F 2 e 8
and now Capablanca goes night to e1 he
wants to make room for his pawn to come
to f4 we have Bishop to d6 getting the
bishop to a more active square with f4
and now s capablanca has pawns on d4 and
f4 he does have a hole here
on e4 and selector uses it we have
Knight to e4 Knight captures Bishop
characters and now Bishop to d3
Capablanca wants to trade off everything
with Knight to f6 Bishop captures Knight
captures and sorry about that Knight
captures and now rook the c2 with ideas
of bringing this Bishop to c1
if this bishop can come to c1 then kappa
blanka can push b4 and the position will
be very nice the bishop from c1 will be
guarding the a3 pawn and Dirks can be
doubled depending on on what black plays
either on the sea or on the D file and
here is a position where black is
definitely better but capablanca often
went into end games and he would just
outplay his opponents but here to his
misfortune conflict plays the absolute
best idea here he was rook to a 4 with a
double attack against the c4 pawn so
Capablanca has the capture you cannot go
B 3 or something as the a3 point is weak
so we have pawn captures and now pawn
captures and now there is this threat
for example if you play something like
Luke d c1 then capturing the bishop is a
threat because now your pawn on e3 is no
longer regarded simply rook captures and
the black would continue most likely
winning this game but after each
captures on d5 we have Bishop to c1 as
Capablanca plant and now before is
definitely an idea and the da3 pawn will
be protected with b 5x like the grebs
more space here rook to c4 will be an
idea in the future and here we have
Knight the d3 Capablanca also wants to
use the very nice a5 square for his
night much like Selecta is using the e4
square for his Knight and here f6 was
played which is a good move it prevents
the knife from jumping to e5 but
Spielman suggested that maybe erupt the
c4 was a better idea
maybe Knight the e5 isn't such a threat
here because after rook captures and B
captures now you're gonna force the
Knight to e5 either way and now after f5
that black would have a better game here
with the dark square Bishop not really
seeing all that much action this rook
can come to a
you can push b5v for it would be a black
would have some moves to play while
capablanca not really but okay we have
f6 and now comes Knight to f2 capablanca
used this maneuver threatening g5 to
remove over to f2 and now he wants the
trade of this very strong night and here
if you try something like let's say this
to pull before or something then white
and simply capture and after pawn
captures now white indeed can go before
prevent black from going before and now
everything's protected the bishop is
protecting the a3 pawn and black will
not be able to break through here so
after Knight 2 f2 we have rook a back to
8
now if Knight captures the rook can
capture on e4 and then black can if he
wishes so double up rooks on the e-file
Knight captures on e4 kappa blanka does
go for this we have rook captures and
now King to have to bring the King into
the game
we have g5 and now g3 strengthening the
DF for pawn king to f7 sorry King to f7
King to f3 in bringing the King closer
into the game and now h5 and here
Capablanca finds a very interesting
solution he plays h4 now either trying
to get like to push g4 to completely
close down the position after king f2
like it's gonna go f5 and now after B
force played it will be very hard for
black to break through here
so select I decided to go for a
different approach G captures on h4 and
now not capturing here and allowing row
g8 for black to take hold of the open G
file but instead rook to h1 a very nice
idea because now if you go something
like H captures and g3 it's not a
problem
Oroku capture on h5 and this pawn is
weak it will be captured very soon after
King g6 roguish 3 is coming and now
after rook to e8 pressuring d3 pawn I
will just have rook captures and g3
checking a5 or or f5 can get 5 and now
the other group can come to h2 the
bishop is guarding the B to pawn the e3
pawn this row can come to h5 and deliver
check it's actually kappa blanka who
would be better here so after rook to h1
we have f5 l
white the capture on h4 and then the
king will block the position we have
rook captures on h4 here King to g6 and
now rook c2h2
pressuring the h5 pawn and now schlechte
has to move the other hook all the way
to the King side to help out with the
defense of the h5 pawn with rook to 88
and now comes before finally from kappa
blanka and now the whole position is
completely blocked there is no way to
break through here and it was in this
position that josé raúl capablanca and
kölsch lexa agreed to a draw in round 9
over the 1911 San Sebastiano chess
tournament the a3 point is protected by
the bishop there is no breaking through
here capablanca has a very firm grip on
the c5 square so any any breakthrough
will not be possible this rook cannot
move it constantly has to keep an eye on
the h5 pawn this rook if you gave it all
the moves it wants it would still not
find any any purpose so there's there
simply no way of black to break through
here and but also there's no way for
white to break through here so a draw is
well an understandable result yeah
that's around 9 on the 1911 a sense of
osteon tournament I do hope you enjoyed
it and that you are enjoying the
coverage so far once again if anyone can
shed some light on this mystery from the
newspapers why there why missus is there
and cross collector is not I would be I
would be very happy but you know it's
it's just weird so yeah I would like to
thank Fernando establish the Oliviera
Paul Hearst handed every diamond plate
violets and Marcel Fernandez for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous video so your think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content yeah thank you all and have an
excellent rest of your Friday